every single character has to have
something really compelling that they're
fighting for or want you know um they
can't just be
who taught you how to write a screenplay
let's see i mean i
i don't think any one person tom had
every screenplay i i definitely have
read lots of the screenwriting books you
know and things that
you would be told to read you know like
save the cat or all the other ones you
know
um and i think those things are super
helpful because knowing that structure
is really important
you know the podcast like script notes
you know think anything like that like i
think it's just
as much of that information you could
take in is is super important
but i think at the end of the day you
just have to start writing and then you
have to kind of figure it out you know
and i think at least for me because
again that's how i really shine and
learn is is just by doing it and so
you know i had been writing stories ever
since i was a little kid i mean i made
my first movie when i was eight years
old you know and so i had always been
kind of writing and telling stories and
so i think it is something i've been
kind of working on my whole life
and even when i wasn't making a film i
was maybe doing something else whether
it's a commercial or this film festival
i ran i was still in some way kind of
telling a story to an audience or or
kind of
creating some sort of experience right
and so
um
i think it's it's writing is one of
those things you're probably like
filmmaking is some element that's just
born in you right that has that in you
and then it just takes a lot of time of
just doing it and getting practice doing
it i mean i think the books and other
resources can give you a lot of
inspiration and also really good at
letting you then pick apart your stuff
and figure out what's not working in it
but in the end of the day i think you
just have to kind of do it and kind of
almost make yourself good by just by
doing it enough
how do you start writing a screenplay
like
i mean me personally i start with
the
i guess the big picture concept what is
this about
um
from there i would talk about i would
think about you know who
are the characters um
what's going to be compelling and what
are the stakes here
um
and then i think from there kind of
trying to figure out the structure you
know i mean obviously
there's lots of structure to a feature
script not that it necessarily has to
have that but that's kind of how you
usually write it is kind of figuring out
these acts and different points of the
story right and i think that was helpful
for me with this feature just because
uh borrego is in a sense a kind of
action movie it is that kind of more of
a commercial feel even though it it has
a lot more to it than that but it was
still helpful to kind of have those kind
of maybe beats and things along the way
to kind of work towards
and i think that is super helpful to
kind of know okay i have this much for
that and that much for that
not to be stuck into that but it was
helpful to kind of um
give me something to work towards
um
but
i don't know i'm not an expert i don't
think there's one perfect way of writing
a script but i think really it is
important to have what is that really
compelling idea and what is
what is the really interesting things
about each of these characters that make
you want to watch them and create a
story and drama from because if you
don't have that i think you're really
going to struggle when you get to
actually physically writing the words of
every scene and so i think
now more than ever when i write
something
it's kind of really doing as much diving
into it before i even start writing to
kind of make sure i have that there
would you see an ellie or a guillermo
and kind of study them a real life and
just you come from afar and just
envision
yeah that that and then try to
incorporate some of that into the script
yeah i mean i'm definitely someone
wherever i go i'm always watching people
and you know i i definitely think i take
a lot from from real life i mean i think
that's one of the best things about
traveling too is you know wherever you
are especially if it's somewhere out of
your comfort zone you know just seeing
some little moment or something can give
you so much inspiration i mean i'm
always writing down ideas and and little
things i saw are people i i talked to or
a conversation i heard you know i think
uh that's definitely a great way to i
think that's probably partly why you
become a better writer usually as you
get older too is that you just have more
life experience you've we've witnessed
more characters you've had more stories
and i think that's something where
um you know as you're a younger
filmmaker you probably have to really
pull more from yourself or from your
family or things like that and find
those connections because
obviously there's just so many rich
characters out there in the real world
that you can definitely pull from for
sure yeah
what about the dialogue for these
characters did you
did it take time to refine it because i
mean they have a very interesting
relationship i'm sure more in the
midpoint or
for sure yeah i mean dialogue is
definitely something that's that's
always really hard with with a script
right is to make that sound really
authentic and real and
um you know for me when i write i really
kind of perform the scripts you know
like i'm really not an actor but i i i
need to speak out loud when i write the
script and so
i'm i'm really almost like acting out
the movie as i write it and so i think i
actually do a lot of it before i even
write it down i'll kind of be saying it
over and over again so i i do spend a
lot of time with the dialogue to kind of
try to make sure it sounds realistic
and of course
your first draft is probably never going
to be great but as you go on that's
really what changes probably more than
anything is the dialogue i think the
actual structure of the film is really
similar to what it was in the first
draft but what's different
is other than some character probably
development expanding is a lot of the
dialogue and just continually working
that to make that sound real and then
that really also continues when you go
to make the movie i mean obviously some
directors and writers are very strict
about their scripts but i was never like
that where
uh if the actor has another idea for a
way to say this you know that's great
and especially in my case the film has
several scenes in spanish which i'm not
fluent in spanish at all and so in those
scenes especially it was very important
for those actors to kind of take
ownership of that and be able to
say this in a way that was casual or
slang or however they would say that but
even in the english scenes like i mean
uh i try to have each of the actors be
able to take something from their own
life and bring it to that character and
so we did a lot of you know adjusting
even before we shot the film of like you
know what is this not something you
would you know do or how could we make
this more relatable to you and
hear some words we could change here and
there and you're even doing that on the
fly while making the movie you know like
doing a take and that didn't sound right
like what else could we try you know and
so
i think to get really believable strong
dialogue it's just always about
experimenting and and kind of tinkering
with it i guess um that's that's really
at least how i approach it
what makes your writing process
different from everyone else
i mean i can't speak for too many other
people because i don't know
that many other people's writing
processes but
i mean
mine has been
evolving i guess i mean
i haven't written that many things right
and so it's it's kind of constantly
learning i guess what works i think the
thing i just recently have been writing
is this limited series that i've been
developing and
i think for me
it was it was trying to take as much
lessons as i learned from the first the
last script which is just that
the characters really have to have every
single character has to have something
really compelling that they're fighting
for or want you know they can't just be
existing they really even if we don't
know in the story
hear every detail of it i have to kind
of know that exists and have it in my
head so
i most recently kind of wrote a whole um
page or two on every character you know
and what was their backstory and what
was their life like and all these things
that are maybe they won't even make it
into the script but i think i'm just
doing as much kind of pre-thinking and
planning as i can now you know where
i'll just be kind of meditating on it
for a long time and i'll get an idea and
i'll take a voice note or something and
i'll i'll record that and i'd spend a
lot of time thinking about it before i
even started writing it and at least for
me that's i think what turned into a
really one is it was a lot easier to
actually write it when i did write it
and then two i think it's the strongest
writing i've ever had and so i think
the more time you can kind of just let
it all sink in i think does allow it to
kind of marinate and kind of uh
be even stronger
in the script for borrego that's like a
three-year
marination
i well for brego i think it was it was
slightly different i probably more in
that sense doving quicker with the first
draft and then spent a lot more time
adjusting and changing and refining
whereas the thing i've more even more
recently written that hasn't been made
yet um i probably spent more time
marinating but then less time actually
writing to get something really strong
you know um
so
i don't know if there's one perfect way
or anything but at least for me i think
that's what i found to make something
really compelling is if i spend a little
bit more time just kind of letting it
all sink in before diving in to write it
what was it about borrego that just you
couldn't stop writing
um
i think
there was just this personal connection
for me with the film both with this this
idea that started with my dad based on
kind of him as this amateur botanist
um but then two just the desert itself
was a character of this movie you know
really was like the fifth or sixth
character of the movie was this
landscape and was this desert and i
think just having grown up i spent so
much of my childhood camping and going
on these desert adventures with my
parents that was just where they went we
didn't go to like
you know really disneyland or other
places we did once but mostly we went to
the desert and i wandered around the
desert and thought of ideas and was you
know just in that kind of world and so i
think um i just knew this was such a
compelling setting and so few things had
kind of been set specifically in this
desert almost nothing had been shot
there
and i just loved that kind of movie you
know this is almost like a neo-western
of sorts you know it doesn't it doesn't
really feel so much like a western but
it kind of has a lot of that vibes and i
do like that kind of film and so i just
knew this was gonna be a good film you
know i knew it was really important to
make a film that i wanted to make a film
that people wanted to see i didn't want
to just make a film that was
too intimate and it would never get seen
i wanted to kind of make this blending
of worlds where it had this kind of
commercial appeal with some action and
excitement and thrills but also wasn't
just that fluff either it had
dynamic characters that were interesting
and authentic and
was something that kind of this blending
of films that maybe doesn't exist as
much and
i just knew that if i could pull that
off i could make something really really
interesting that people would want to
see
do you believe that there are writing
dead ends or that a writer can always
find a creative solution
out of sort of a what seems like
they can't go any further
i think definitely you could you could
reach a dead end if you didn't probably
do enough thinking ahead of time and and
kind of figuring out if this idea was
going to work you know perhaps
um
i've never not finished a screenplay or
something but i know a lot of people do
struggle with that where they get to a
point they can't keep writing but i
think that's probably just because you
you probably started writing too soon
before you really figured out what is
this character's
i don't say motivation but kind of you
know all those kind of typical things
like what those are real like what
what what is it this movie's really
about and what is it this person's
fighting for whatever kind of genre the
film is
um of course you can reach those kind of
temporary dead ends probably all the
time struggling with writer's block and
all that kind of stuff
but i think in terms of ones that you
can't get out of it's probably started
because there's something missing in
your kind of development of the overall
concept
did you have any troubles with borrego
let's say the second act or the ending
anything where it was just a little bit
more time spent on it
yeah for sure i mean
i think
the second act is always the hardest
just because the first act is just
setting up you know you're kind of
even if you don't have the idea figured
out you can kind of set that story up
and get it going right
and the ending you hopefully know the
ending or where it's going and the stuff
in the middle is usually what's the
hardest because it's longer usually and
it's what has to kind of keep the
momentum going and so i think that's
probably where i
had the most challenge of kind of
figuring that out um
and
uh
i think also the some challenges i had
is as i got into trying to actually
finance this film
i did have to start cutting back certain
things in order to make the budget work
so i had to start cutting some scenes
and trimming some areas
and so then it kind of came
more like a bit of a puzzle of like okay
what could i take away that won't hurt
the film but it will make us
a cheaper film to be able to make and so
i think it's always this kind of
constant kind of journey with the script
especially if you're making the script
to direct
it never is this perfect linear process
i think
what makes us care about the characters
in borrego so i think in borrego we care
about the characters because they all
have something that they're they're kind
of fighting for or dreaming towards you
know so
even the we'll say bad guys in the brego
um they're not really
evil people you know they they've gotten
into a situation that
um
they
they uh
they didn't necessarily want to be in
but it's where they are you know so in
one case
you know they needed to support their
family and so they took a job doing
something they knew that was wrong or
illegal but it was their only choice you
know or
um
someone is running away from something
in their their past and
they're trying to put it behind them but
um they know it's going to catch up with
them but they're just ignoring that and
i think there's something that we can
all relate to in all these characters
most of us aren't drug dealers and
crossing the border and all that but
you can still find the humanity in these
characters and and that was something
that was super important to me because
you know i really wanted to be super
sensitive to making a film about these
kind of people and and this border story
because i'm not from that world i don't
live that i have lots of friends who
have family members who are from that
and could talk to them about that but i
really wanted to try to tell this in as
i guess gentle and authentic as a way
possible where it wasn't really about
that the film
sets that up and that's what sets up the
story but ultimately it's about just
these individual people and what their
choices are and what their beliefs are
and what they're
fighting for in their own life
and that's really what the film is about
so i think that's what makes it unique
and
and compelling for people to watch